some of the really fascinating research
on subjective well-being shows
Cepeda ng it and at recognizing it to me
the the experiments that have really
really shattering is are the dime on the
on the copy machine students come in and
they're gonna take a questionnaire and
they're told well you have to photocopy
the questionnaire before you take it and
so there's a photocopy machine right
over there and there's a dime that
somebody's left on the copy machine and
everybody sees that they pillow and put
in the pocket but then when you look at
them and that and the questionnaire is a
deep questionnaire about how well their
life has been going so far yeah and if
you found a dying your life as a whole
has been going a whole lot and find it
on write another survey I think it uh
döner group did this one this was done
telephone you call people up it's a
phone survey and you're asking them
about their life and how well it's going
and compared with what they wanted and
so forth and you've got a weather map
you know what the weather's like there
and half the time you ask you comment on
the weather usually how's the weather
there today and they say always a
beautiful sunny day the other half you
don't say anything about the weather it
turns out if you ask about the weather
you cancel the effect because they
notice it's nice it's a beautiful day if
you don't ask you about the weather then
if it's sunny there their life has gone
a whole lot better as a whole then then
if nothing now these are these are very
robust they've been they've been
duplicated a many times and it really
does sort of stop you in your tracks a
little bit and you realize that if you
had a dream of harnessing science to get
people to characterize what their own
well-being is and then will try to
maximize that you realize that it's a
sort of a will of the wisp that isn't
necessarily I mean if we could do it
would be something else if and and and
it's worth remembering that since we
can't do that and practically we tend
always to just fall back on money you
know that's the thing you can count and
but we should never forget that what we
really want to maximize is something
which doesn't come in units that can be
counted and that that's probably even
the wrong approach to thinking about
about well-being because oh yeah one
other one of the other features and you
mentioned the hedonic treadmill it is a
very strongly confirmed fact that
paraplegics as a group have a greater
life satisfaction they feel better about
their lives and then millionaires then
multimillionaires now given that though
can you imagine going to the to the
christening or bar mitzvah of your of
your friends finally saying may you grow
up to be a paraplegic
there's explanations about this and it's
very much what Owen was exactly to the
paraplegics I have to brutally
reconsider and rework their sense of
what's going to be important now
and they do a pretty good job of it
you